[Music]
will you be directing a star is born
oh god yeah that's just a rumor I love
to see directness as something I'd like
to pursue absolutely Bradley Cooper
speaking his goals into existence with
the movie everyone is talking about the
Oscar nominee is making his directorial
debut with a star is born
he's also starring in the movie
alongside none other than Lady gaga
I think you're beautiful Bradley's
version marks the third remake of the
1937 film the most recent was 1976
starring Kris Kristofferson and Barbra
Streisand and it even won an Oscar
[Music]
it's been 42 years since that version
hit the silver screen
ever since tons of a-listers have been
reportedly attached to a revival
Jennifer Lopez Leonardo DiCaprio Tom
Cruise and Beyonce were all rumored to
be involved at one point or another but
it seems the stars were truly in
alignment for Lady gaga who signed on
during summer 2016 just months after she
won a Golden Globe for her very first
role on American Horror Story hotel
who's the little mouse now proving she
is not only a six-time Grammy
award-winning artist but she's also an
award-winning actress a true triple
threat
[Applause]
lady gaga is that is the female carries
unbelievable I think really is
incredible me and Bradley work really
well together I'm very grateful to him
it's just an incredible experience I'm
the music expert and he's the acting
expert you know so we get to sit
together and teach each other things so
he really makes me a better actress
Bradley also confirmed to Ellen the
romantic drama will have all new
original music
[Music]
and yes that's really him singing baby
it's time Olivia
I just hope I can just be believable
enough so that you can watch Stephanie
it's just about like it's her name Gaga
just shine because she's incredible
no surprise here celebrities are just as
excited as we are I can't wait to see it
congratulations that's exciting I notice
he'll do a great job she does every time
she performs I'm so excited I will be
there opening night front row right
popcorn ready a star is born will first
screen August 31st at the Venice Film
Festival and opens in theaters October
5th
[Music]